how often do you watch the news and feel
like this guy what and all are we doing
here here are some of the stories from
this week that made us asked that very
question in the epic battle against Isis
I rocks Air Force cable whole new
meaning to the term operation dumbo drop
when they accidentally delivered food
water and ammunition to Isis supplies
were meant to go to Iraqi soldiers who
desperately needed them but he said they
helped out the very guys they're
fighting when Obama said he
overestimated the strength of the Iraqi
army this week he may have had a point
that's true but it's not like his secret
service has been any more impressive
knock knock who's that back there the
armed intruder breaking into the White
House and as we learn thanks to a giant
Secret Service fail the intruder got a
lot farther than previously admitted
because somehow in America's most
guarded home with two full-time snipers
on the roof Omar Gonzalez and Iraq war
vet managed to do the following climb
the White House fence run across the
lawn open the unlocked front door and
bolt his way through the eastern before
finally being stopped makes the White
House Crashers of 2009 look a bit
classier no surprise then that the
director of The Secret Service got
grilled by Congress don't let somebody
get close to the president that is
unacceptable and I wish to God you you
protected the White House like you're
protecting your reputation here today
she resigned the next day the kicker is
that after the hearing news leaked that
just a few days before the intruder
incident the Secret Service somehow
allowed a dude with a gun and a criminal
record in this same elevator as the
president in his visit to Atlanta but at
least the White House has now changed
the locks change you can believe in and
finally the annual spectacle of
international political theater known as
the UN General Assembly came to a close
this week highlights included the 2014
version of the same speech benjamin
netanyahu gives every year iran iran
iran Hamas Isis Hamas Isis and once
again visual aids came in handy to
really help him get his point across but
it was India's new Prime Minister
Narendra Modi who offered a nice
solution for the world's problems yoga
ie I'm a anti rastriya yoga us Karim
Carnegie de jamon cardiac arrest there
is then but maybe a bit too late for the
1000 people killed in religious riots on
his watch when he was Chief Minister of
Gujarat in 2002 want more download the
aj+ mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store now